-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Chris Hayes.
You wrote a "New York Times"
essay.
-I did.
-Making the case for why you
wanted Twitter to survive.
I think that this is a time
where a lot of people
talk about
what a cesspool it is.
I liked reading about the fact
that it has also been
a wonderful place.
-Yeah, there's lots of things
that have been
really remarkable about it.
I mean, one of the things
I think --
The thing that was best about it
is, because of how
it was structured, in which you
weren't necessarily just in one,
you know, one part of Reddit,
right,
like, "Oh, I'm an electric car
enthusiast,"
I'm on, like, the Reddit board,
you had this sort of general
feed, and because of the way
retweets worked
and the algorithm,
you would happen upon stuff.
You know?
And so for me as a --
particularly as a news gatherer,
you know, there'd be
an impending railroad strike,
and then all of a sudden
I would have like three or four
people that work
on the railroad talking about,
like, "This is why we want
paid leave," and this is why
this new system they use
in the railroads is totally
oppressive and brutal,
scheduling-wise,
and you would have this
for a million different
experiences.
You would get these windows,
and again, that could be
dangerous because a little
knowledge is a dangerous thing.
Like, I know about the railroads
now, right?
-Yeah.
-I followed these three people.
But I found, for me, the breadth
of experience and perspectives
that were all mixing in one
place, there really hasn't ever
been anything quite
to replicate that,
and I don't want it to go away.
-And what do you think in the
early days of Elon Musk's,
you know, running of Twitter --
are you -- I mean, again,
you're not a business guy,
but are you basically thinking,
"He's nailing it," right?
-[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's 10 out of 10.
As far as I can tell.
-10 out of 10, yeah.
Every part of it.
-I mean, I'm not in the books
but I think pretty much --
-[ Laughs ]
-Sounds like pretty much --
No, it's been pretty disastrous.
I mean, I think the thing
that I actually have --
that has been clarifying for me,
I think there was --
First of all, it felt a little
bit like an impulse purchase.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-Like he was at the cash
register and there was like
a $44 billion
social-media company.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So that was weird, that he --
It was the most expensive
impulse purchase of all time.
I think that what he's been
doing with the platform now is
actually very clarifying to me
because it wasn't about
the business and it wasn't
an impulse purchase.
It was an ideological purchase.
And as long as there have been
rich people,
and as long as there have been
rich people and capitalism,
plus a free press, there have
been rich people who buy
media outlets
for ideological purposes.
This is a story as old as time.
And once I sort of saw it
as that, I was like, "Oh!
That's what this is."
He wants to own Twitter because
he wants to pursue his vision
because he's
the world's richest man.
The other thing I think is key
here is --
You know, I'm one of
these people who is
A, a Twitter addict, and B,
it's, like, "partly my job."
-Yep.
-It's like if you're, like,
working at RJR Nabisco, and
you're like, smoking two packs
a day, you're like, "Well, it's
the product. You know?
I gotta test it."
-[ Laughter ]
It's like, that's sort of me.
But that's also Elon Musk.
I think he bought it so he could
be like, "I'm working."
-Yeah!
-[ Laughter ]
That's so smart. Right.
Like when my wife is like,
"Are you still on Twitter?"
-Like, "I'm working!"
-"I bought it, honey!"
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-I gotta be on it. I bought it.
Can I just say you crushed
Twitter from the start?
-Oh, this is amazing.
-We went back and looked.
And like a lot of us, it took us
time to figure out how to be
good at Twitter, but we went
back to your first four tweets.
This is April 12, 2007.
I want to reveal them as we go.
So, that's "working on
a presentation in Keynote."
Thank you for that.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yep.
One heart right there.
-One heart, right.
-[ Laughter ]
-Hearted it up.
-By the way, like, imagine
retweeting that.
[ Laughter ]
Like imagine someone being like,
"Oh, I want my followers
to see that."
Alright, then you
come back with,
"in a coffee shop
working on a draft."
[ Laughter ]
More likes but less retweets.
-Mm-hmm.
-"Reading blogs
and craving caffeine." Oh!
-That was a perpetual
state of being.
-And then this is
maybe the most --
the flattest tweet
I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
"Listening to Terry Gross."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, at least I'm not --
-Now, I'm -- By the way,
I listen to Terry Gross.
I love Terry Gross.
I've never, while I've listened
to Terry Gross, think...
-Tweeted that?
-..."I gotta let people know."
[ Laughter ]
-At least I'm not a caricature
of myself.
I will note, for my -- to defend
my honor here, briefly,
do you remember back then
the Twitter prompt was,
"chrislhayes is..."?
-Ah!
-That was the prompt.
The prompt was like --
It was like a status away
message.
Like you used to have on AIM
back in the day, people our age.
And so, like, the setup was,
"What are you doing right now?"
-Tell us what you're actively
doing right now.
-Exactly. Just, you know --
-Okay, gotcha.
But I evolved.
I think I got better.
-You know, listening to
Terry Gross sounded boring.
But just to make it fair, you
should have heard it like this.
"Chris Hayes is..."
[ Laughter ]
"...listening to Terry Gross."
-[ Laughter ]
-Thank you!
Right? Better.
-There you go.
-Better.
-[ Applause ]
-You know, you tease yourself
for being very online
and living an online life.
It should be noted,
another thing that's remarkable,
you and I are very much inside
that Twitter bubble.
We think it's the most important
social-media network
in the world,
and it is decisively not.
-No, definitely not.
And it's never, you know,
delivered a ton of growth.
It's never been particularly
far-reaching.
It has always been
a bit of a bubble.
And again, I also wonder how
much this -- you know, again,
going back to that point about
you can't extrapolate out some
trend and -- because there's
disruption and there's changes.
I don't know if this era we've
lived in basically, I think
since the introduction
of the iPhone in 2007,
which is the kind of
fully smartphone, web 2.0,
social-media universe that we've
lived in now for 15 years.
I don't know if we're at
the precipice of something new.
You know? It feels to me like
there's shifts happening.
I don't know where it goes next,
but I also feel -- There's a
little bit of an end of an epoch
feeling to me right now.
-You also do a good job -- If
the the epoch ends and it's more
outdoorsy, you're also
a very outdoorsy fella.
-I know.
-You clear some brush.
-The silence in the crowd is
the surprise registering.
-[ Laughter ]
-But you did something.
You posted this photo of you and
your wife on your anniversary.
And this is last July.
-This is our 15th anniversary.
-Your 15th anniversary.
And where did you take her?
-The garbage dump.
[ Laughter ]
And I will say the fact that --
I mean, I do think
that's a good test.
At 15 years, if you can make out
in front of a pile of garbage --
[ Laughter ]
-And in my -- I just want
to be clear here.
This was not unilateral.
This was a --
We were both psyched.
-Okay, that's nice.
-Together to go --
Kate's parents were in town.
They nicely spelled us
for a little bit.
We had a lot of garbage
piling up.
We headed down to the dump.
We were like, "Let's together,
after 15 years, cross this item
off our to-do list."
-That's really sweet.
-Together.
I think that is --
That's the foundation of love.
-Chris Hayes is
finding true love.
-Yes, under a garbage dump.
-Under a garbage dump.
Hey, thanks for being here.
-Thank you, man.
-We're looking forward to
following you tonight.
You guys, that's Chris Hayes.
"All In with Chris Hayes,"
weeknights at 8:00 on MSNBC.
Tune in for the network's
continuing coverage of
the Georgia election.
We'll be right back with
Charlotte Nicdao.